what are you drinking
tequila tequila yeah it's colored
tequila you know what I got my first
bottle and I still haven't had it so I'm
gonna have it did you bring it I I did
not bring it I should have brought it
wow I know I you know what I thought you
were here we'll have a drink afterwards
but it's so good to see you it's good to
see you too I'm getting a little
emotional because it's in person it's
been a long time it's been too long it
has Hawaii was the last time thank you
for saying that you look great too thank
you yes check's in the mail for saying
that thank you very much but you've been
going through so much the last few days
so you're in a good place right now
right you're feeling the energy the Mana
feeling the energy feeling the Mana I
have it has been you the last time I saw
you was in Hawaii yeah and the last time
I was here in Canada was I couldn't
remember the last time I was here in
Canada which tells me that's a problem
and I've been gone too long so I'm so
happy here we are you know the Canadian
national anthem right you want to sing
it no do you know go Kevin Hart Oh
Canada our home and native see oh you
could say thank you I think I can sing
I'm pretty good but first thing first
how's your mom I always ask you it's
good thank you so much for asking yeah
sure she's gonna watch this and she's
gonna love that you asked her no she's
settling in I got her house
um and she's doing so good and you know
she she lives her best life every day
every day and I love that and just as a
son that's what you want you know I love
that yeah she's gonna have to add the
Black Adam suit to her Shrine that she
creates for you yeah congratulations you
thank you so much tour
at this point
what does Black Adam represent to you
personally in your journey
um
I like that you waited three minutes
before you come in with the Deep
question
Black Adam represents
represents resilience represents
commitment represents passion this has
been a 15-year Journey a 15-year fight
to get the movie made a 15-year fight to
keep the movie on track
and here we are so this I've been saying
this a lot recently because we've been
on this Whirlwind press tour but it's
true and I mean it it's from my bones
when I say that Black Adam is the most
important movie I've ever done in my
career
and um and arguably could be the most
important that I will ever do because
for me Black Adam everything that I've
been able to do in the past and
fortunate enough even wrestling back in
the days where I was like suplexing
fools here at the sky dome
um
it all led to Black Adam it all led to
this
you know a lot of people are talking
about especially your fans that The Rock
just saved dceu has been a thing yeah
straight up was this a plan for you and
Danny and yeah it's a lot to take on the
well the plan and goal wasn't
necessarily to save uh it was DC it
wasn't to save DC but the plan was I
think three-prong number one was let's
create a great movie and I think that's
important uh number two let's build out
the DC Universe at the same time
and number three and quite possibly the
most important is let's listen to the
fans
so in the spirit of that the plan wasn't
hey let's save the DC Universe because I
didn't think the DC Universe needed
saving but what it does need
it needs much better leadership
and it needs much better I think
it needs a much better aperture to go in
and truly listen to the fans and by
doing so I've always felt and this goes
back to my days of wrestling even before
I got to WWE when I was wrestling in
flea markets you know in state fairs and
things like that for 40 bucks a match
um
I listening to the fans will always
guide and inform you where you need to
go
so here we are movie comes out in about
a week
um
the movie now is picking up now that
people are seeing it and they're really
understanding now oh this is what he
meant by
um
uh a new era in the DC Universe this is
what he means by listening to the fans
so we're gonna deliver I know I was
watching it and all I was saying
every like it's so good congratulations
thank you so much
in a theater and even at the end of
everything was just it's amazing and the
suit the hoodie do you remember the
first time wearing it and shooting your
first scene and that feeling what do you
do what was the first scene and were you
nervous or were you more excited I
wasn't nervous I was excited I try not
to get nervous I try not to put myself
in situations where I get nervous
because I like to prepare for things as
best I can
um I I wasn't nervous I did have a
moment though in my trailer when I put
the suit on for the first time I looked
at myself in the mirror I said holy like
you say uh when you watch uh Black Adam
but the holy [ __ ] was
I did it like here we are and we did it
this has been not only a lifelong dream
but for Danny and I and Hiram who you
know it's been a family dream yeah I'd
give you a little story uh and when you
see her you can bring this up okay when
I first I first met Danny who for those
of you don't know is my business partner
a long time business partner and ex-wife
when we first met I was 18 years old I
went over to her apartment the first
thing she showed me when I was 18. uh
was her collection of Superman comic
books and then here we are years later
so it's a family dream for Black Adam
anyway uh I digress I put the suit on
and I'm like holy [ __ ] we did it we're
here I go to set I go directly to our
director John mccolette Sarah we start
talking about the scene he said how do
you feel I said I feel great I'm ready
to go he goes he said are you ready to
create the um the uh Dirty Harry of
superheroes wow I said I am
and then if putting on the suit and
having that holy [ __ ] moment wasn't
enough I happen to look up and I see
walking towards us
all four members of the Justice Society
all in their costumes that's amazing
holy [ __ ] oh my God
come on man it was amazing so I just
remember that was a that was a full
circle moment on set day one and I see
everyone walking towards me and I was
really proud to put on my costume yeah
even more proud to see these four actors
walking towards me and talking about
family you know you're super dad to your
kids I try to be yeah and tia thinks I
think she knows you're Maui now she
knows I'm Maui yeah that's good does she
know now that you are a superhero a
protector with superpowers wearing super
spandex
yeah crew don't laugh at that don't
encourage her the super spandex
no they do know that they know they're
so excited about Black Adam and there's
a lot of there's just a lot of black
Black Adam is in The Ether of our house
so there's a lot of talk about it I've
had a lot of conversations with them
which is interesting in their six and
four Minds just for them to try and
understand or interpret the philosophy
of are you a bad guy daddy like they
always keep asking me that because this
when you they see the trailers yeah I
mean I'm doing some
pretty violent and I said well no
daddy's not a bad guy he's more of a
protector of the people who he loves and
I love the videos of them throwing
peanut butter on you there's a water
bottle no water water balloon well
there's a favorite game we play called
daddy closure eyes yeah who's the master
it's the little one isn't it it's both
of them really yeah well here
this is an indicator of what the future
will look like so Daddy close your eyes
when Jazzy says it who's six uh usually
it's peanut butter to the face whipped
cream to the face she goes in my
bathroom she's taking all my products
and putting them all on you know foil uh
like get the water balloon when Tia says
daddy Close Your Eyes the last time we
played daddy close your eyes I closed my
eyes and she came up she hit me right in
the balls just like a straight shot
right in the balls
and they love and they laugh I can't do
anything no no no but squeal you know
what but you know what I do love about
those videos is your smile and that
you're taking it in I mean that's what
makes you a superhero I love it what
have you learned from your kids
to allow yourself to experience pure joy
I've learned
to allow myself to experience that pure
joy is do my best to be present because
life is so busy we're all so busy you're
busy I'm busy everybody's busy
especially when your parents man you're
wearing a lot of hats you're running
around you're doing a lot of stuff
and time is easy to get away from you
and especially in these little moments
you know it's like okay I gotta go we
gotta go you always gotta go so I've
I've learned over the years
um
to really slow down in those moments and
when it's Daddy close your eyes then
I'll close my eyes and everything else
will wait yeah everything else will wait
because I also realize because I have a
21 year old Simone that that time flies
by man you know we were just talking
about that your daughters are getting
older too so time flies and I want to
take care I want to embrace and be as
present as I can in this in this time
that I have with them during this
especially this critical age the daddy
close your eyes because there's going to
be a time where they're not going to
care and hanging out with daddy's not
going to be cool so while it's a little
cool for them to hang out I'm right
there and you started this press for
talking about the Pres not running for
president right now you're putting that
on hold but has anyone ever asked you if
you were in charge what you would like
to change in the country you love that's
going to make it better for your kids
um we haven't gotten into those deep
conversations you know those are always
uh uh they're intriguing I think to
think about and talk about I think that
um
what has happened over the past the
course of the past
four to six weeks is I have had
um
the most influential people on both
sides of the aisle the both parties
approach me which has been really
interesting which is really
um
uh supercharged
decision making and conversations on
will you do this because if the answer
was yes I am going to do this for 2024.
I got to declare in about a month and
top of the year yeah we have to get
going yeah anyway
um which won't happen but um no to be
honest with you I haven't gotten into
those conversations conversations so now
that you're putting that on hold would
you like to win an Oscar is that in your
plans
I would love to win an Oscar one day I
don't know you know you imagine like who
would sit across from you I don't think
so
you know some
you know something well it's not that I
don't want that I would love that of
course I'd love to stand on an Oscar
stage one day yeah and and think about
what that Oscar speech would look like
who I would thank who I would how I
would speak right would I have something
prepared a lot of people who I know who
won Oscars I'm like you know I tried to
prepare something and then it just went
out the window
um no I would like to sure